[MUSIC PLAYING]
PAUL SAXMAN: Hello, and welcome
to this week's episode
of Google Maps Developers
Live.
I'm Paul Saxman.
And with me this week
is Brendan, The
Tessellator, Kenny.
BRENDAN KENNY: That is
what they call me.
PAUL SAXMAN: Yes.
And this week, we're going to
talk about some advanced
visualization techniques
using WebGL.
And specifically, we're going
to talk about a library that
you recently ported from C
to the JavaScript, right?
BRENDAN KENNY: Right.
PAUL SAXMAN: To do exactly what
your title describes,
tessellation.
BRENDAN KENNY: Yeah.
Yeah.
So this one, this library,
it's a--
I don't know what I'm
trying to say.
It's a little bit
of a step back.
It's not necessarily
an application.
It's more of a tool that you
can use for applications.
And so we're going to mostly
talk about the tool itself
today, and show some examples,
but not anything that will be
really mind blowing.
It will be more like, this will
be useful if you need
this sort of thing.
PAUL SAXMAN: I don't know.
I mean, maybe for the uneducated
of us, maybe
explain what tessellation
actually is.
Because for graphics guys, it's
pretty straightforward.
BRENDAN KENNY: So the reason
that we need this--
in the past, we've talked about
how it can be useful to
draw WebGL stuff on
top of a map.
It gets you a couple
of things.
It gets you really
good performance
for a lot of things.
So say you want to put even
millions of markers down or
something like that.
You can't do that today with
Canvas or any of the mapping
libraries out there.
So, you need to cluster, or
generate tiles, or whatever.
But with WebGL-- putting WebGL
on top of a map-- you could do
that, if you wanted to.
You'd have to think about
the usability of
those millions of markers.
But you could, if you wanted
to, is the key.
PAUL SAXMAN: And we talked about
the trick with all this
is using what we [? presented ?]
at the
previous show is the
CanvasLayer.
BRENDAN KENNY: Yeah.
So, there's the CanvasLayer
library.
You can just Google for
that, one word.
It's the top result.
And it's in the Maps API
utility library.
And what it does is it just
sticks an HTML5 canvas as a
layer in your Google Map.
And then you get
a handle to it.
And you can draw whatever you
want to it, whether that's 2D
Canvas or WebGL.
So points are easy.
But a lot of geographic data
is in the form of polygons.
And the problem is that WebGL
can only draw triangles.
That's the simplest primitive
there is that has area.
But the fact is that most
geographic data actually
stores things as polygons,
both for efficiency and
because it's kind of
a more natural way
to describe an area.
And so you need something to
be able to draw polygons.
So you get speed.
But you can also do things like
you can start getting
custom effects per pixel, and
do crazy lighting, or just
things based on demographic
data or whatever.
All these things are unlocked
when you can really do fancy
WebGL, especially if you want
to do it for, say, every
county, or every country,
or political
district within some area.
So yeah.
So the key is that
we need to make
triangles out of polygons.
And then there's another layer
of things where geographic
data is also extremely messy
usually, whether it's coming
in in real time-- in which case
you excuse for polygons
to backtrack on themselves and
intersect with themselves and
have repeated vertices within
their descriptions--
or when you don't really
have an excuse.
You get a file from a customer
or something like that, and
maybe the file format says that
all the polygons have to
the wind a certain direction
and not self intersect.
But inevitably, someone will
give you a file that's
horribly garbled and you need
to display it on screen.
So you have to deal with
both of those things.
We have to make triangles, but
we have to make triangles out
of nasty data.
PAUL SAXMAN: And there's
also doughnuts, right?
BRENDAN KENNY: Right.
Yes.
And so then you can
have multiple--
like in KML--
rings where some define inside,
and some define holes
on the inside of the polygon.
So it's complicated.
And so we kind of looked around
a few months ago.
And we're looking for kind of
libraries that would let you
do that, and do it
efficiently.
And there wasn't really
a lot of options.
There's a few triangulation,
or tessellation
libraries out there.
But they're not necessarily
super fast or super stable and
really let you throw
anything at them.
So I decided to port the GLU
tessellator which is the--
GLU is the OpenGL utility
library from years gone by.
Originally late '80s, early '90s
is most of the code, so
generally about 20 years old.
PAUL SAXMAN: And kind of an
interesting piece of trivia is
that it was probably written
over in the Google Main
Campus, which was then SGI.
BRENDAN KENNY: Right.
So the implementation that I
was looking at was the SGI
open source implementation,
which was written just a few
blocks next door.
Actually, it says you can go to
that address and get your
software license in writing,
even though Google's there
now, not SGI.
So let's take a look.
If you go on GitHub and you
look for libtess.js.
Libtess is the name
of the library.
It implements the GLU
tessellator interface.
You can see it.
And right now you see
license information.
And actually, there's no
examples right now, so I'm
going to rectify that after
this with the example that
we're about to look at.
And you can see kind
of how it's used.
It's a little esoteric.
It's very C-like.
So it was originally C code.
And I left it as close to the
original interface as possible
when I was porting to make
sure that it worked.
And now that it's working, I'm
going to start looking at
options for more JavaScript
interface.
There's lots of enumerated
property values that you pass
in and flags.
And there's a weird mix.
And I don't know if this has
to with just historical
reasons, but there's
a weird mix of--
for some things, you actually
pass in call backs.
You pass in function pointers
in the C code.
And sometimes it's like you get
this insanely long switch
function based on different
enumerated values.
It's a weird mix.
And there's no reason it needs
to be like that, because
there's not going to be a lot of
legacy code that people are
going to be using here.
So why not make a
new interface?
But for now it's very C-like,
which is what we're going to
be talking about today.
So can see the information
and the license.
The license is kind of a weird
SGI-specific license.
But the Free Software Foundation
has actually worked
with the remnant of SGI
to get it under a
nice friendly license.
And now it's fully compatible
with all your--
it's BSD-like, but it's also
compatible with all your other
Copyleft licenses.
So feel free to use it.
Rip stuff out of it.
Do anything you want with it.
So let's look at an
example first.
Sound good?
PAUL SAXMAN: [INAUDIBLE]
BRENDAN KENNY: Oh, right.
Let's go full screen.
So here is all the--
well it's basically zip codes,
but it's actually pseudo zip
codes from the Census
Department, Bureau, whatever,
in California.
And I think we have, I don't
know, a few hundred-thousand
triangles make up
to this drawing.
This is actually from a
shapefile parser that Mano
Marks ported over
to JavaScript.
And so it parses a shapefile.
And then it takes all those
polygons and runs it through
the triangulation, the
tessellator library, to make
polygons, and then fills them
in with random colors.
I just picked random colors.
But you could imagine that this
is based on zip code data
or demographic data.
And I think we actually showed
this a month or two ago on one
of our visualization
sessions with Mano.
And if we get down to it, you
can actually see this handles
well even cases where there's
holes within polygons, where
there's smaller zip codes
within larger zip codes.
And if I open up the
console here--
ooh, that's fun.
Let's pop it into here.
If we open up the console, we
can then make a function.
Let's see.
Change places, I call it.
And so what this does is it
loops over all the zip codes
and assigns a random
color to them.
It just takes picks a
random RGB value and
assigns a random color.
And then I call Schedule Update
on the CanvasLayer,
which just calls a paint.
So if I call that, everything
will change to a random color.
And then if we just want to
make sure that we have the
proper disco party feel,
we could actually put--
let's put that in an interval,
because why not?
It's like the blink
tag, but for Maps.
PAUL SAXMAN: Don't cause
any seizures.
BRENDAN KENNY: Yeah.
So I'm going to put it
at 500 milliseconds.
So it's a little slower.
We can do it at the frame
rate if we wanted to.
And now--
PAUL SAXMAN: That's the
amazing thing, right?
So you have I don't know how
many polygon on there.
BRENDAN KENNY: I think
this comes down.
Yeah, I don't know.
Actually, I should count the
number of zip codes.
But even in LA, you have just
a crazy number of--
including these ones.
I don't know if that's due to
the post office, or if it has
something to do with
gerrymandering at some point
in the past.
PAUL SAXMAN: So it's like
political boundary.
BRENDAN KENNY: Yeah.
It follows rivers.
And I guess that's because
they tried to get at
neighborhoods maybe at some
time in the past.
But yeah, so you can
make really amazing
beautiful maps like this.
But the key is that we're
redrawing all these triangles
in real time.
And if we wanted to
do at 60 frames a
second, I could do that.
But I'm refraining, because I
don't think the video will
even record that.
PAUL SAXMAN: Brendan, you've
reinvented the blink tag for
Google Maps.
BRENDAN KENNY: Exactly.
For Maps.
So if we refresh here, I can
show you a little bit.
I can switch the mode so it's
actually drawing lines instead
of polygons.
So it doesn't draw all the
triangle lines, because I'd
actually have to change the
triangles to do them
differently.
But if we zoom in on one of
these zip codes, we can see
kind of what's going on.
So it's not the prettiest
triangulation.
It actually breaks things down
into these mono polygons,
which are polygons
that are easily
splittable with triangles.
So you have some more modern
techniques involved like
Delaunay triangulations where
you can get optimal angles
where you maximize the size
of each triangle.
But the nice thing about this
is that it's super stable.
It's also well tested.
It's 18-year-old code.
And software projects will just
import it directly and
not make any changes, because
they know that it's been so
well time tested that
everything's stable.
PAUL SAXMAN: And it works.
BRENDAN KENNY: And it works.
PAUL SAXMAN: I mean, you can get
60 frames per second out
of this code.
BRENDAN KENNY: Right.
PAUL SAXMAN: Or your
tessellation, it looked like
it took one second.
BRENDAN KENNY: Less than
a second, yeah.
800 milliseconds for about
890 triangles.
890,000 triangles is what
you end up with.
And it can be faster.
When you profile it right now,
about 20% of the time is spent
on garbage collection, which
we can eliminate.
We have the technology, but that
will come in the future.
So it's fast.
And Delaunay triangulation is
not necessarily bounded except
for if you make compromises.
It's execution time.
And for graphics, this
is usually fine.
You can deal with these
skinny triangles and
do per pixel effects.
If you're doing a numerical
simulation where you're
showing the spread of heat,
or I don't know, zombie
infections or something, you
might run into some numerical
problems with these
skinny triangles.
But it's fine for
the most part.
And you can tell it's
completely stable,
even as we zoom in.
Way in here, these things
share a border.
And as a result, you can't see
any break between them.
Stray pixels.
So that's this.
It's pretty exciting.
It's pretty fast.
PAUL SAXMAN: So what are some
applications of this?
So you mentioned we can actually
get all the counties
in California.
BRENDAN KENNY: Right.
PAUL SAXMAN: So what are some
other things you can do with
this technique?
BRENDAN KENNY: As I said, it
really comes down to we have
geographic data that's in
polygons, and if we want to
draw polygons, we need some
way to draw polygons.
So anything you need to draw
a polygon for today
you can with this.
So that's not necessarily an
application in itself, but any
reason that you need to.
So an example would be if you
have effects per zip code.
But if you imagine zip codes for
the entire United States,
and you want to change that
per frame, there's nothing
right now that you could
draw that in real time.
You could draw it statically.
You could draw its 2D canvas
and not change anything.
But as soon as you pan or
zoom in, you'd have to
redraw it all again.
And that takes some time.
And this would do it virtually
instantly.
But then as soon as you want to
run effects across those,
you wouldn't be able to do that
at 60 frames a second.
PAUL SAXMAN: Can you do things
like for example, instead of
filling the polygons, can we
actually just get the stroke
and stroke the polygons?
BRENDAN KENNY: Yeah, so you
can get that outer border.
And the cool thing about that
is that you can actually
adjust the winding order and
then do kind of shape algebra.
So you could find the union
or the intersection
of different polygons.
And you can do that real time.
And so if you wanted to do
something like take the area
of some effect, like some
environmental thing, and then
intersect it with zip code data
to find out exactly which
zip codes are affected by
this, you could do that.
And you could do that offline
or something already.
But this let's you do it
in 60 frames a second.
And as you move your blobby
thing around, you could find
out that intersection.
And also the great thing about
libtess is that it will take
extremely degenerate polygons.
It will take the nastiest
polygons you can throw at it.
It'll take any winding
order that you want.
So whether you want it to be
clockwise is inside and
counterclockwise vertices is
outside, or the opposite, or
you have two clockwise, but you
want to count one as the
outside, you can just specify
that you want even winding
orders to be outside
if you want.
PAUL SAXMAN: It's really
friendly to kind of dirty
geographic data--
BRENDAN KENNY: Right.
PAUL SAXMAN: --which
we regularly see.
BRENDAN KENNY: Exactly,
which is actually
most geographic data.
And you don't necessarily have
time to sit there and say,
well, they input this
data, but they
probably meant this data.
So do you mean fix
it this way?
And instead it's like,
just draw something.
And if it doesn't look
reasonable, then you say, OK,
let's fix your data.
You don't want to sit there and
say, well I can draw it
for you as soon as you
have reasonable data.
So here's the example that I'm
going to be including with
libtess in the repository.
And this is just a simple
triangulation.
And all I'm doing is kind of
making a circle and then just
adding a random radius
to each point as I
go around the circle.
Just to give you an idea.
So we can look at the actual
code that does this.
And as I said, it's kind
of nasty C-like code.
It's very flat and there's no
real object hierarchy you have
to worry about.
But on the other hand, it's very
verbose, and you think
about all the different
properties you have to set.
So here's the triangulate
function if we
look here in Dev Tools.
And you can ignore this.
The triangulation actually
supports triangulation in 3D.
So you can actually do an X,Y,Z.
But we just set zero
for all our z-coordinates.
And so I have this--
I call it Tessy-- but it's the
tessellation object that you
just call the new GLU
tessellator And when you're
ready to start, you say,
begin polygon.
And you posit the array that
you want to put your final
vertices into.
You loop over contours,
it's called.
Sometimes they're
called rings.
Sometimes they're called
faces, even.
And that's each ring
of vertices that
make up your polygon.
So a polygon can be made up of
multiple rings or contours.
And they could be both additive,
so that they
actually add area
to your polygon.
And they can be subtractive, so
they actually take away and
make holes in the polygon.
And so we just loop
over our contours.
And so for each--
we have begin polygon
on the outside.
Inside of that, we have begin
contour and in contour.
And you have as many of those
as you have contours.
And then within that,
you have vertices.
You set each vertex,
one at a time.
For each contour,
I begin contour.
And for each contour, I then
loop over vertices.
And for each vertex, I
then add that vertex.
And then finally, we
say, end polygon.
And that's when it actually does
it it's calculation and
spits out your triangles.
So here I'm just getting
the triangles directly.
But there's a lot of things you
can do with things like,
just give me the
outside border.
Or it can actually split it
up into triangle fans and
triangle strips, if that's
more efficient
for your use case.
And there's a couple different
things it can do.
And then you can do crazy things
like get the outside
border, and then run it
through it again and
triangulate the outside border
so that you're not ignoring
all the internal lines
that you might have
had to generate triangles.
Whereas by default, it will
actually generate triangles
within those.
PAUL SAXMAN: And all these
functions are built into
libtess, right?
BRENDAN KENNY: Yeah,
it's all built in.
Yeah.
PAUL SAXMAN: So we have some
kind of documentation on
[INAUDIBLE]
BRENDAN KENNY: Yeah.
So it's all documented.
It's closure style docs,
so it's even
typed, if you want that.
You don't have to use it.
It's not enforced.
It's just enforced by the
Closure Compiler.
But the nice thing about that
is that it can compile down
and eliminate dead code.
And I think it's about
7K with gzip.
So it's pretty small when
you get down to it.
So finally, this array that I
passed to the tessellator in
the beginning is now full
of my triangles.
And now I do my normal
WebGL stuff, which
you can look up elsewhere.
But you could use 3GS.
You could use any library
you want.
Or you could use plain WebGL,
which is what I used in this
example, to create an array
buffer, pass it to your GPU,
and then say, draw it.
So you can see here in
this example that I'm
drawing this polygon.
And every time I refresh, it
adds different randomness.
And so this takes about nine
milliseconds to tessellate.
But that's actually misleading,
because that's
before the v8 has had time you
to profile itself and then run
Crankshaft to optimize
your code.
So this gets down to less than
a millisecond, usually, when
you run it through a
couple of times.
And now, actually, I can do the
same thing and set fill
mode equal to false, and
schedule an update.
And you can see, once again,
the lines that are drawing
here, which is exciting.
So what I do here is I just
generate a circle.
But let's say I wanted to add
another circle to make a
doughnut, as you said.
So I can go back to my code
and [? uncomment ?] this.
So this just makes
another contour.
So I have an array
of contours.
This makes another
contour with a
slightly smaller radius.
And I said a counterclockwise
flag here, so the internal
one, the slightly smaller
loop, will be clockwise.
So it's opposite.
So now if I go back to Chrome
and I refresh, I now have a
nice thing here, which
is very exciting.
PAUL SAXMAN: Can we see
what the polygon--
BRENDAN KENNY: Sure.
PAUL SAXMAN: --or triangles
look like?
BRENDAN KENNY: So it's a little
confusing because it's
drawing these lines which
aren't actually there.
Because they are individual
triangles, if the next
triangle is way across the
polygon, it will actually draw
a connecting line.
But it's enough to give you an
idea of what it's doing.
It will actually create the
two borders and then find
those polygons that it can
easily triangulate first.
Not quite [? greedy, ?] but not
that far off, to find what
it can tessellate.
So, yeah.
So there you go.
PAUL SAXMAN: And as a developer,
you're not that
worried about the lines.
I mean, once it's tessellated,
you're
not working in triangles.
BRENDAN KENNY: Right, right.
PAUL SAXMAN: You're still just
working in polygons.
BRENDAN KENNY: Right.
PAUL SAXMAN: And you take the
vertices out, if you need to.
BRENDAN KENNY: It's more
WebGL that needs
to worry about that.
But it interpolates it
across correctly.
And as you can see, there's no
there's no visible artifacts.
And as we refresh, we can
see the nice dance of.
And so this scales
fairly well.
If we go back here,
we can say--
PAUL SAXMAN: Quick question.
Are all the vertices part of
your original polygon?
So the tessellation library
doesn't create vertices?
Is that true?
BRENDAN KENNY: Let's see.
Is that correct?
Yes, except intersections.
So where lines intersect, it
will split both lines and
insert a new vertex
between those.
Now the two line segments become
four line segments.
So yes, other than that, it
won't create any new vertices.
Which is part of the problem
with some of those uglier
tessellations is that really
what you want to do is create
internal vertices and
use those to kind of
split up the space.
But that becomes a much
different problem, because
then you're minimizing energies
rather than just
doing kind of more deterministic
working through
your vertices.
So just to show that this is
very possible, we can scale
this up to like 5,000 vertices,
because why not?
And suddenly we get kind of this
insane fuzzy thing here.
PAUL SAXMAN: Which
is just because
you're scaling the radius.
BRENDAN KENNY: Yeah, so
the radius is a random
0.1, plus or minus.
And so you get kind of
this really fuzzy--
whoa.
I don't know what
happened there.
And it's actually somewhat
difficult for the tessellator,
because when they're so close,
they might be intersecting.
And so it has to check.
Every time you get a new one, it
actually has to check from
either side if it's
intersecting.
And it's a sweep line method.
And so anyway, the point though
is that it can handle
this quite rapidly without
any issue.
And if we do this again, we can
see that the lines become
almost as complicated as the
filled version, to the point
where it's no longer a
useful visualization.
So that's it.
I'm going to put this
example up.
And so that should make the
library a little bit clearer.
And then look for some
interesting applications of
this in the near future.
But I just wanted to get this
out there and get people
introduced to it.
And if you have any issues, if
you have any suggestions about
the JavaScript interface, if you
have things that you wish
that it could do but it
can't, let me know.
I'm going to work on
performance and
the JavaScript interface.
And yeah, that's what's
coming up.
PAUL SAXMAN: Cool.
All right.
Well, thanks a lot.
So thank you everybody
for joining us today.
Again, if you want to find the
code, GitHub, search for
libtess.js.
BRENDAN KENNY: Dot js.
So there's a lot of libtess's
and libtess2, but they'll be
C. So you want to
look for dot js.
PAUL SAXMAN: And the
example's coming.
And if you guys have any
questions, comments, put them
in the comment section of
YouTube, and we'll get back to
you as quickly as we can.
So thanks again, and
see you next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]